The father of Peggy Carter's children has
been confirmed, and all we can say is, we
need a movie featuring them right now.
Avengers: Endgame screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely have gone on record
confirming that Steve Rogers is, indeed, the
daddy of Peggy's two kids.
This raises…well, several questions, but
first, a little background.
Marvel Cinematic Universe aficionados are
well aware that Peggy Carter, onetime agent
and eventual director of S.H.I.E.L.D., is
the long lost love of Captain America's life.
At the conclusion of 2011's Captain America:
The First Avenger, he failed to meet up with
her for a promised dance due to an unforeseen
plunge into an icy ocean, and an even-more-unforeseen
70-year hibernation.
This haunted Rogers for years, and he was
only given a slight semblance of closure when
he visited a now-elderly Carter in her hospital
room in 2014's Captain America: The Winter
Soldier, in which it was revealed that Carter
had married, and had two children.
"I have lived a life.
My only regret is that you didn't get to live
yours."
Carter's death during the events of 2016's
Captain America: Civil War shook Rogers to
the core, and it seemed as if he were destined
to forever live in the shadow of what could
have been.
But amazingly, Avengers: Endgame, in which
the team time-traveled to various points in
the MCU's history to collect the Infinity
Stones in a bid to reverse the effects of
Thanos' infamous finger snap, gave Rogers
the opportunity for a do-over.
After the defeat of Thanos and his armies,
Rogers was tasked with journeying back to
the points in time from which the stones were
taken, in order to ensure the timeline's integrity.
He did so, but in a shocking twist, he then
chose to remain in the past, finally getting
his dance with his beloved Peggy and living
out the peaceful existence he so richly deserved.
So, what's the deal with Peggy's two kids?
Markus and McFeely cleared it up in their
sitdown with THR, and what they had to say
will bend your brain in more ways than one.
"Ahh!
My brain!
Raah!"
First up, McFeely confirmed that the little
tykes were fathered by Rogers when he explained:
"It was always our intention that he was the
father of those two children.
There are time travel loopholes for that."
Now, pay close attention to his phrasing:
It was always their intention that Rogers
was the father of Peggy's children, and again,
these are the guys who wrote Captain America:
The Winter Soldier.
Talk about a long game; did they somehow have
an idea that time travel would come into play
in the MCU years down the road?
How could they have possibly known that?
It's mind-blowing to think of the conversations
that must have taken place between these two
as they crafted Winter Soldier's narrative,
and even more so to think that apparently,
some of their wildest imaginings for where
the Infinity Saga could one day go apparently
came to fruition.
Markus then chipped in with an offhand remark
that just might mess with your head even more.
He revealed:
"It does introduce the idea that there are
two children who have somewhat super soldier
DNA."
While this revelation might cement Steve Rogers'
legacy as a super-dad amongst the likes of
Clint Barton A.K.A.
Hawkeye and the late, great Tony Stark, it's
not the first time Cap's fathered a couple
kids.
In the 2008 animated movie Next Avengers:
Heroes of Tomorrow, Steve's son, James Rogers,
joins forces with the other Avengers' kids
to do battle against Ultron.
Not only that, but the What If comics propose
an alternate reality where Rogers hooks up
with Rogue on the patchwork planet Battleworld,
founds a colony there, and fathers a daughter
named Sarah.
If you'll excuse us, we've got to go write
a detailed pitch for a TV series chronicling
the adventures of Peggy Carter and Captain
America's super soldier children.
Here's something we still haven't quite worked
out, though: the existence of Carter's children
was established years before the Avengers'
time traveling shenanigans.
If Rogers weren't destined to go back in time
and stay there, would those kids have had
a different father?
Or would Carter never have had any children
at all?
Try not to think about it too hard; we wouldn't
want you breaking your brain on our account.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.